[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département a c'est
parti pour le sommaire handball en
nationale 2 montigny le bretonneux s'est
imposé ce week end dans son gymnase
contre le deuxième du classement le
havre résultat qui permet aux signé
monteyne de quitter la dernière place du
championnat
tous les détails dans ce set 8 sport
football ont joué ce week-end le premier
tour de la coupe de france le club
deville pro a réalisé l'exploit en
s'imposant au bout du suspense trois
buses adieu compo draveil une équipe
classée une division au dessus des bills
provient plus de renseignements à suivre
karting nous recevrons dans ce magazine
le nouveau prodige des circuits jimmy
elias le guillant pour toi viens
d'intégrer la prestigieuse écurie tony
kart et participe au championnat du
monde
son manager christophe perrin
l'accompagnera sur ce plateau
coup de projecteur maintenant sur les
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département
[Musique]
on commence par du handball féminin en
nationale 2 montigny le bretonneux en
difficulté dans ce championnat engrangé
sa quatrième victoire de la saison
contre le havre ce week end
score final 23 à 20 à des images de
nicolas d'andré un succès rassurant pour
montigny le bretonneux dernière du
championnat de nationale 2 avant la
rencontre lésigny montaigne se sont
imposés 23-20 contre le havre dans un
match maîtrisé de bout en bout
franchement on est parti jouer le match
vraiment son stress pour se faire
plaisir et faire notre jeu
vraiment très content à l'entraînement
on a fait des choses simples pour pour
généreux mobiliser un petit peu les
joueuses pour la remettre en confiance
retravailler énormément la finition
parce qu'on avait beaucoup de beaucoup
de duels perdus face à la gardienne
donc ça c'est le travail de toute la
semaine et je pense que ça a payé
avec cette quatrième victoire de la
saison lésigny monteyne pointe désormais
à la 11e place sur 12 équipes engagées
une place anecdotique car aucune des
simples et condamné cette année avec la
nouvelle réforme du handball l'occasion
pour le staff de tester certaines
joueuses en vue de la rentrée prochaine
au travail pour l'année prochaine c'est
ce que j'ai dit mais j'ose qui
travaillent qui l'ont placé pour l'année
prochaine
donc allez-y à fond vous prenez pas la
tête jouez comme vous voulez jouer comme
je vais dire comme vous le sentez
et puis surtout faites vous plaisir est
là se sont fait plaisir pour continuer à
se faire plaisir montigny le bretonneux
se déplacera le samedi 12 mai sur le
terrain d'aubervilliers l'équipe qui les
devance d'une place au classement
on continue par du handball mais cette
fois ci un masculin ont joué ce week-end
pour le compte de la 18e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 plaisir a
réalisé une mauvaise opération ce samedi
soir en s'inclinant sur le terrain de
marolles 28 à 26 leur deuxième défaite
en trois matches un résultat qui peut
avoir un impact sur la suite du
championnat
plaisir perd sa deuxième place au profit
de son adversaire du jour et n'est plus
à barragiste pour la montée en fin de
saison
prochain match pour les plaisirs oit le
13 mai à domicile qu'on l'entend contre
l'entente pcn on ouvre maintenant une
page football ce dimanche soir un ebe
noah a brillé avec guingamp face au
paris saint-germain en clôture de la 35e
journée du championnat de ligue 1 selon
ludovic blast le joueur de 20 ans qui a
fait ses débuts en sept ans au club de
rambouillet aujourd'hui espoirs de
l'équipe de france inscrit un superbe
but en pleine lucarne avec 44e minute de
jeu une réalisation qui ne permettra pas
aux guingampais de l'emporter score
final 2 buts partout fois le psg jouera
à d'ailleurs la finale de la coupe de
france le 8 mai prochain contre les
herbiers un club semi professionnel
un parcours que villepreux club de
troisième division de district espère
imiter dans les prochains mois la
première étape a déjà été affranchis les
villes présents se sont imposés lors du
premier tour de la coupe de france
contre les essonniens de draveil un club
classé une division au dessus des
yvelinois le résumé
match les images sont signés à nicolas
d'andré une victoire au bout du suspense
ville pour a réussi à se qualifier pour
le deuxième tour de la coupe de france
grâce à ce coup franc zidanesque
pourtant rien n'a été simple pour les
villes projets en face à draveil
mené 1 0 et réduits à dix en début de
match les rouges ont réagi pour me les
deux buses avant la mi temps
malheureusement non croix rouge un peu
compliqué car accepter malgré qui fixait
les règles
il fonce à accise statut faut-il sont
pas un carton à dix contre onze on est
en train de faire du 2 1 on continue le
travail qu'on entraîne pour faire depuis
des matchs et des modes de travail va
finir par payer à la fin au retour des
vestiaires les villes provient souffre
face au pensionnaire de deuxième
division de district draveil fini par
égaliser de but partout sur quand même
enfin quand on est revenue en ont fait
du compte on défend des solidaires et on
a défendu peut-être un peu trop bas un
but encaissé qui a servi d'électrochoc
villepreux poussé fini par marquer le
but de la victoire dans les dernières
secondes
score final 3 buts à 2 sa délivrance
c'est le résultat de deux mois et de
mois de travail une délivrance allait
jouer une équipe eu une division au
dessus on va en plus comme il l'a dit 80
minutes à dix c'est compliqué c'est là
la récompense comme je l'aurais dit dans
le petit message ça reste de france
c'est la télé qui vient il ya les
supporters sur l'arrière 6 8 faites vous
plaisir avant tout ce sera un résultat
prochain tour proville pro début juin
contre un adversaire encore inconnu les
supporters eux commence à prendre goût à
la coupe de france dans les autres
rencontres de ce premier tour de coupe
de france parmi les principaux résultats
à bois d'arcy est allé s'imposer sur le
terrain de vie licence sur jean sur orge
mort pas englouti l'équipe les petits
pains 9 à 2 elancourt s'incline 3-2 à
domicile contre savigny foot voisins le
bretonneux s'impose 1 à 0 sur le terrain
de villemoisson la verrière domine
facilement vignes 3 1 victoire sur le
même score de montigny le bretonneux sur
le terrain devra en football américain a
cette fois ci ont joué pour le compte de
la 9e journée du championnat de 2e
division
on dans un match capital pour la montée
les templiers d'elancourt se sont
inclinés 24 à 16 sur le terrain du
leader les spartiates d'amiens
une défaite qui pourrait compromettre
leurs chances d'accession à l'étagé
supérieur prochain match pour les
templiers le 12 mai prochain à domicile
contre les diables rouges de à
villepinte
après le football américain du baseball
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
n'ont pas fait de détail ce week-end
contre les boucaniers de la rochelle
désigne montain l'ont emporté ce
dimanche 13 à 3 dans la première
rencontre et 12 à 3 dans la seconde
partie
deux victoires qui permettent aux saint
quentinois d'être quatrième du
championnat de première division avec
deux matches de retard
on continue ce 7,8 sport part du un
karting les yvelines pourront peut-être
se vanter dans quelques années d'avoir
vu grandir
un pilote de formule 1 jim il ya cinq
ans pour toi de 9 ans affole les
compteurs
après avoir remporté ces dernières
années le championnat de france de
karting
aujourd'hui il use ça gomme sur les
circuits des championnats du monde en
italie nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
sur son plateau
jim elias avec son nouveau manager
christophe perrin bonsoir alors ses
débuts sont-ils encourageant alors bah
oui je pense que jimmy déjà démontré
toute cette vitesse de pointe et pas
plus tard que ce week-end où on était
assis ensemble pour une première année
parce qu'il faut pas l'oublier il est
quand même très jeune c'est une première
année où il apprend tous les circuits
les nouveaux châssis rouler dans un
environnement qui lui est complètement
nouveau
il faut également que ça qui limita qui
s'acclimate à l'anglais à l'italien un
petit peu ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
changements pour jamie je trouve que
pour l'instant pour une première année
ils s'en sortent plus que plus qu avec
les honneurs jimmy ce que je pense faire
pouvoir faire mieux c'est possible pour
moi j'ai encore beaucoup à apprendre y
est réussi il garde la tête froide
malgré ces il y relate est très froide
et il est très travailleur
donc ça c'est une qualité qui est qu'on
peut retrouver chez tous les tous les
grands champions donc c'est ça aussi qui
me qui me donnait envie de pouvoir le
faire progresser faire arriver au plus
haut point et c'est une catégorie où il
ya beaucoup de pilotes internationaux
dans ton équipe
il ya plusieurs nationalités 1 si j'ai
bien compris oui qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve comme nationalité par
exemple un chinois han saoudien en
français un chèque république tchèque
et voilà d'accord les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux on peut tout à fait les
meilleurs pilotes mondiaux font leur âme
dans ces catégories là et comment on
fait pour le pour gérer quand on est à
un manager à bas le but c'est de
de faire prendre conscience à ji min ou
de tous les enjeux et de tous les
pourtours tous les petits détails qui
vont faire au final la différence sur la
piste donc
jimmy a indéniablement un talent naturel
qui est qui est assez important
maintenant avoir du talent ça ne suffit
pas et donc là bas moi je suis là pour
essayer de lui apprendre et lui faire
prendre conscience de de tous les deux
tout ce qui est autour et comment bien
gérer une séance d'essai calif
comment se comporter avec les
partenaires parce que ça fait aussi
partie du métier de sportif de haut
niveau
donc voilà alors tu as rejoint tony kart
racing team récemment l'un des plus
l'une des plus grosses écuries de
quartier pourquoi parce que y'a bon veut
y à beaucoup de niveaux et j'aime bien
cette écurie est est ce que ça te permet
selon toi de t'améliorer beaucoup
beaucoup à apprendre
tony kart c'est vraiment à christophe la
meilleure écurie aujourd'hui c'est oui
c'est les meilleurs fournisseurs de
châssis on peut dire aussi que lyon
bénéficie d'un encadrement assez
exceptionnel avec marco ardigo qui a été
multiple champion du monde de karting
qui est là pour encadrer les jeunes et
pour les former vraiment donc on va dire
que pour moi ça tony kart aujourd'hui
dans le monde du karting c'est la
meilleure école et c'est vous qui l'avez
conseiller oui vous êtes son manager
depuis cinq six mois c'est relativement
récent une qu'il avait conseillé tout à
fait et donc tony kart fonctionne aussi
également avec ferrari driver academy
est ce que c'est un tremplin pour aller
chez ferrari
alors oui ils ont fait ce que le
raccourci un peu facile ans et ils ont
un partenariat avec effectivement la
ferrari driver academy donc ça donne
lieu à des rencontres entre les pilotes
qu'ils y font partie de la ferrari
driver academy et les jeunes de tony
kart c'est effectivement l'occasion de
créer des des liens intéressants avec
cette académie là maintenant ça veut pas
dire forcément que jim ira chez ferrari
où c'est c'est une occasion de créer des
liens mais en tout cas le partenariat et
entre tony et la ferrari driver academy
alors jamie tu as un nouveau kart cette
année qu'est ce que vous qu'est ce que
tu en penses
le sous vos cartes très bien eh bien il
va vite
oui comme vous disiez finalement le tony
kart c'est les meilleurs sur le marché
en ce moment way est tout à fait suivant
les catégories parce qu'il ya plusieurs
catégories donc ça démarre à 9 ans ça va
après vous pouvez rouler jusqu'à plus de
20 ans même si vous le souhaitez mais on
va dire que tony kart dans toutes les
catégories dans lesquelles ils sont
passés ils ont appris et ils ont gagné à
un moment donné donc on va dire c'est
vraiment une référence en la matière
dans le milieu et comment on fait pour
façonner un talent comme jimmy vous avez
côtoyé de grands pilotes de f1 sur ces
15 dernières années notamment botas
esteban ocon kobayashi pourquoi ces
pilotes ont réussi
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vous en
tant que manager pour aider jimmy pour
atteindre ce niveau là alors déjà je
pense qu'il ya une caractéristique et
caritas tous c'est la détermination
je pense que les 3 que vous venez de
citer montré une détermination un peu
hors du commun et jamie à cette
détermination là donc ça c'est c'est
quand même en dehors bien sûr du talent
naturel vous avez beaucoup de pilotes
qui ont du talent mais soit ils sont pas
travailleurs soient ils ont pas la même
détermination et c'est ce qui peut faire
la différence
après il faut également de
l'intelligence il faut également le goût
du travail
donc c'est des qualités que quand jimmy
parce que des pilotes qui vont très vite
mais qui sont pas très malin il y en a
aussi beaucoup
il a ce petit truc gémit way jimmy à ce
contrat qui va cette intelligence il a
ses idées à 7
pas plus tard que ce week end il a fait
un très beau dépassement dans une manche
au dernier virage du dernier tour d'une
manche
bon il a su attendre le bon moment pour
pouvoir mettre son dépassement il a
suivi sa montre une certaine déjà une
certaine vague maturité malgré son
malgré son jeune âge
jimmy quel est ton plus grand rêve est
pilote de formule 1 et champion du monde
enfants myla est ce que tu as un modèle
parce que c'était pas nous connaissons
par un oui tout à fait et esteban et son
parrain sportif son parrain sportif
ouais donc comme esteban ocon oui vous
laisse à tous les deux bah oui moi j'ai
eu l'occasion de travailler avec lui
pendant sa carrière et en gp3 et en dtm
tant que c'est vrai que j'entretiens en
plus particulier qu'est stéphane donc
c'est vrai que c'est un truc on sait ce
qu'on lui souhaite en tout cas merci à
tous les deux dettes passées sur ce
plateau on continuera évidemment à
suivre ta carrière jimmy avec attention
est ce que vous êtes des fans absolus de
basket notamment la nba un petit peu je
suis loin un petit peu j'ai mis un petit
peu également le reportage qui va suivre
devrait vous intéresser evan fournier
jour et aux etats-unis dans la franchise
des orlando magic c'était mardi dernier
à carrières sous poissy le sportif
inauguré le quatrième ou pss corner de
france le concept les joueurs peuvent
s'affronter sur deux mini terrain de
basket en indoor des images de mario tac
son visage est connu de tous les fans de
la nba et evan fournier joueurs du magic
d'orlando et de l'équipe de france a
traversé l'atlantique pour inaugurer le
quatrième obscur leur de france à
carrières sous poissy un équipement doté
de deux mini terrain de basket en indoor
pour que les joueurs puissent
s'affronter en 3 contre 3 ça me fait
super plaisir
voilà c'est un projet qui me tient à
coeur depuis longtemps et quand tu es
gamin tu as vraiment de choix soit je
vais en club soit jouée sur les landes
et
donc voilà ça c'est une alternative
différente et
c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai mal au
genou maintenance parce que je veux sur
les plus grandes scènes jallet c'est
donc si la venue ce genre de terrain
j'aurais adoré le sportif de 25 ans
originaire du val-de-marne a également
profité de cet événement pour rencontrer
des jeunes du club de basket de
magnanville il est très bon mais les
gens qui acceptent de prendre des photos
avec donc c'est cool on m'a dit ouais
ligue n'augure à sion 2 ou factory
corner la savait qu'ils allaient avoir
qu'une personnalité que ce soit nbi même
problème pro b même une légende
hermann j avais y allait avoir évolué
fournier ça m'a fait un choc et dès que
j'ai vu dès que même que j'ai dit
bonjour ça ça m'a fait bizarre et joue
en équipe de france et joue dans une
grande équipe aux états unis et enfin
c'est impressionnant de le voir parce
qu'il est comme grand il est balèze est
juste de voir leurs beaux jours de le
ticket c'est impressionnant avec evan
fournier comme pareil avec ces nouvelles
infrastructures flambant neuve loops
quand l'heure de carrières sous poissy
espère attirer plusieurs centaines de
clients chaque mois pour dribbler sur
ces terrains les joueurs devront
débourser entre 40 et 50 euros pour une
heure après le basket nous passons au
ballon ovale le rugby-club de versailles
jouera ce dimanche 6 mai contre roubaix
en 32e de finale du championnat de
france
la rencontre se disputera sur terrain
neutre pour nous parler de ce rendez
vous du beau monde sur ce plateau
nous recevons le responsable
communication du club pierre chevalier
le président éric tournier le capitaine
jean à la mairie bonsoir messieurs
tous les joueurs rêvent de ces
championnats de france en début de
saison pourquoi pierre chevalier c'est
ce qui fait le sel et la particularité
du rugby c'est d'avoir personnes
vraiment où les rugbymans complet
complet c'est une saison ça se passe
d'abord en poule avec des qualifications
pour terminer le plus haut dans une
poule et puis pour justement avoir cette
chance de jouer les phases finales c'est
à dire pour faire comme les grandes
allées chercher un bouclier le bouclier
de brennus pour le top 14
et puis un bouclier tout aussi tout
aussi valeureux moins prestigieux
peut-être pour les catégories en dessous
et c'est le cas en honneur pour
le verset versailles alors là on va
revenir sur cette rencontre contre
roubaix les joueurs se sentent comment à
quelques jours de ce grand match on se
sent très bien on se prépare très bien
pour cette rencontre donc après la
vérité du terrain on verra ce qui se
passe dimanche
en tout cas on observe une belle semaine
d'entraînement avec un stage ce week-end
la cohésion et là on a envie de on a
envie de jouer ce match et on verra on
aura en or
nora tout le monde sur le pré pour faire
un gros match il n'y a pas trop de
stress à l'approché d'un tel événement
non on a tous plus ou moins fait
quelques mois j'ai phase finale dans
notre carrière guy mais je pense que ce
on aborde ce match très bien donc il ya
pas de raison d'être stressé puisque ça
il faut qu'on soit serein dimanche pour
pour faire une belle partie président il
peut y avoir une part de stress sur ce
match car en début de saison je le
rappelle vous aviez annoncé la montée
voit le stress il est peut-être pour les
dirigeants puisque pour les joueurs
clairement on avait affiché en début de
saison une montée en fédérale 3 on a
encore cette possibilité là il est vrai
que nous on prépare déjà la saison
prochaine on est en place tout ça on a
deux hypothèses du coup donc le stress
il est bien un autre niveau et on espère
ne pas le transmettre à nos joueurs qui
ont rejoint un groupe solide
ils s'entendent très bien donc on va
essayer de profiter du bon moment vous
allez allez un petit peu dans les
vestiaires avant la rencontre ouais mais
une terre tout petit on ne pensait pas
très dur mais oui bien sûr parce qu'il
faut il faut être dans l'ambiance et un
regard suffit on sera là dans ce cas
vous tombez donc en 32e de finale contre
roubaix qui reste sur deux montées
successives de ph fédérale 3 champion
des flandres c'est un épouvantail
concrètement pierre chevalier c'est un
tirage difficile c'est une vieille
connaissance du rc versailles parce
qu'on a on a été il ya une dizaine
d'années dans la même poule de fédérale
3 déjà à l'époque donc c'était déjà ce
niveau fédéral que
que roubaix va retrouver effectivement
être en étant de passer de ph ase
honneur puis il a deux honneurs à
fédérale 3 donc oui gros tirage a priori
un très bon groupe qui se connaît bien
là le ccc bleus match peut-être le plus
difficile qu'on aura à jouer le verset
versailles pas ce que c'est
on sort de on sort d'une période de deux
semaines trois semaines sans match
bon après un bon stage et une bonne
cohésion mais dont il ya un tirage un
tiers est difficile ça va être un ça va
être un match rugueux
un match qui va jouer souvent nos
sûrement devant outsider dans ce match a
gravi clairement ont fini cinquièmes de
du comité de france finissent premiers
ils vont chercher le bouclier des des
flandres donc nous on sera outsider
après on a plein de choses à faire
valoir et eon m on mettra le paquet pour
pour que pour passer dimanche et quelles
sont les recettes pour emporter à la
victoire président à votre avis ça
jouera dans l'avant match peut-être la
préparation la rencontre bon je sais
l'avant match je pense qu'on a les
couches qui prépare très bien cette
rencontre il ya des vidéos ils sont très
professionnels et ils ont bien en face
l'analyse deux adversaires le notre
groupe il est 13 unis ils s'entendent
bien il joue bien et quand non je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs il ya sans
doute aussi le climat est ce qui fera
beau et ce que le terrain sera lourd
voilà ça peut jouer aussi après préfère
quels types de terrains secs fait
clairement sec
on n'a pas en fonctionnement et
normandes beaucoup de gros on est plutôt
une équipe qui joue donc clairement face
à à roubaix où on sent qu'il ya d'après
nos informations ils sont costauds donc
il faut espérer qu'ils peuvent paraître
le terrain soit sec et qu'il fasse beau
et pas trop de vent est à ce stade de la
saison de toute façon ça se joue au
mental c
on est on est on est avec des équipes
qui ont qui ont passé déjà une saison
qui ont déroulé en poule et là ça va
jouer des petits détails
surtout surtout dans la tête justement
de l' envie d'y croire l'envi de volant
il progressé lui de passer ce tour-là
après quelques quelques semaines sans
match et puis peut-être un petit facteur
chance aussi qui fait basculer dans un
sens ou dans un autre
dernière question vous compter sur le
soutien des supporters ils font le
déplacement déjà jusqu'à noyon compiègne
beauvais on ne connaît pas encore la cpt
renvoyant compte sur eux ils ont été
très actifs cette année il ya une super
associations de supporters qui s'est
créée pour nous encourager qui sont qui
se déplacent souvent nous voir à
l'extérieur aurait pu à domicile il ya
une sacrée ambiance
donc oui on compte sur eux et puis ça va
faire partie du il faut que le autour de
ce match on a on a hâte que de jouer
aussi pour eux président vous allez
organiser un déplacement
oui bien sûr répond là on attend le net
le lieu mais égale bus
on va sans doute réserver un restaurant
on va on va faire ce qu'il faut pour
pour se mettre dans l'ambiance du match
merci à tous les trois d'être passé sur
ce plateau et bon courage pour le match
de ce week-end contre roubaix ouvrage de
la boxe à présent les longs courtois à
marvin petit a fait beaucoup parler de
lui à cette semaine dans la presse
spécialisée boxeur de la team farrugia a
défié sur les réseaux sociaux
l'américain originaire de baltimore
j'invente à davis numéro un américain et
numéro trois mondial petit protégé de
floyd mayweather qui a réalisé 20 un
combat depuis ses débuts chez les
professionnels pour 19 k o nous avons
joint à par téléphone marvin petit on
les écoute et toutes mes chances et je
suis qui cachera guerrier et je lâche
rien et il n'aime pas les bêtes qui
rentrent dedans
il est perdu et que c'est vrai certains
sont les mots sur l'a20 combavas
victoire 9 ko mais devant qui de mon cul
à peu pour voir aussi devant les mecs
chitika pas la route et prom a aussi
tout se joue dans cette équipe
marvin petit a déjà été un champion de
france champion d'europe et compte 23
victoires en 25 combats charmante à
davies n'a pas encore communiqué sur ce
possible rendez-vous hameau de golf à
présent un très beau plateau prend forme
le prochain à chênée open de france qui
se déroulera du 28 juin au 1er juillet
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
la nouvelle est tombée mercredi dernier
les spectateurs pourront voir sur les
greens saint quentinois pour la deuxième
année consécutive le numéro quatre
mondial l'espagnol de 23 ans john drame
récent vainqueur de l'open d'espagne
quatrième du mythique masters d'augusta
cette année je vous propose de regarder
un extrait de ses dernières performances
[Musique]
je vous
désespéré
[Musique]
lors de la dernière édition l'espagnol
john ram avait terminé dans le top 10 de
l'open de france il a déclaré vouloir
faire encore mieux cette année il espère
surtout réaliser un résultat pour
montrer qu'il a définitivement sa place
pour la prochaine ryder cup qui se
tiendra sur le même parcours que l'open
de france en septembre prochain
on continue à parler de golf et de ryder
cup c'est désormais une tradition ce
magazine tv 60,18 vous propose tous les
lundis de découvrir les plus grands
moments qui ont marqué l'histoire de la
compétition
aujourd'hui le directeur adjoint du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
philippe pilato vous présente l'un de
ses meilleurs souvenirs de la
compétition regardez quand je pense à la
ryder cup en fait cela la première image
et ce qui m'a ce qui m'a vraiment un
passionné dans cette dans cette
compétition c'est 1991 quand il voyait
en fait j'ai découvert le golf dans ces
années-là en 1991-92 est complètement
par hasard sur le web sur lequel j'ai
découvert le golf
j'ai découvert un pull sur lequel il y
avait un logo blogo ryder cup
passionné par l'histoire du golfe
surtout par le côté les origines je vais
voir le projet demande caillois et ça
représente quoi la ryder cup et il m'a
dit eh bien je vais te montrer quelques
images je vais te montrer ce que c'est
qu'à ryder cup et l'on convainc à
l'époque c'étaient encore des cassettes
vhs donc mais la cassette il me montrait
les images et la caisse que je vois donc
ryder cup aux confrontations équipes
américaines européennes
en plus à l'époque il y avait des
figures emblématiques telles que c'est
un haut bas lester ross deus namd
montgomery de côte est américaine
azinger core ip vinh qu'à québec a et
ainsi de suite et qu'est ce que je vois
par rapport à l'image moi que je l'avais
toujours vu dans les bouquins du golf
dans lequel j'évolue et tout ça hein
joue à deux équipes
qui se battent et c'est réellement le
terme parce que dans les comportements à
la fois des spectateurs le comportement
des joueurs dans la façon dont les
joueurs ont également américains ont
fêté la victoire parce que sur ce
tournoi là c'est le marché américain qui
avait gagné ça a vraiment été la
bataille c'est à dire aucun respect des
joueurs les spectateurs qui étaient
limités qui applaudissent et quand les
joueurs européens faisait des mauvais
coups et sa réellement je me suis mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
compétition qu'est ce que c'est que
entre guillemets un petit peu ce sport
le golfe qui paraît si polis ou en fait
attention aux joueurs où on est vraiment
très à l'écouté à faire très attention à
ce que font les autres et en fait cette
ryder cup
ce comportement malheureux on va dire
des américains c'est réellement ça qui
m'a donné envie de continuer et depuis
depuis 1991 je ne manque que jamais
d'édition parce que je trouve que par
rapport à cela par rapport à l'image
qu'on peut se faire du golf du côté
individuel est vraiment là on santé même
si c'était un peu exacerbé un côté
équipe un côté on va dire même
fusionnelle et un côté revendications de
se battre réellement un quelle que soit
la façon pour battre et ramener ce
trophée
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir subi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]